welcome to another edition of famous
Friday where we modeled success of
famous entrepreneurs to help you
accomplish your goals today's lesson is
leverage others and accounts from Joyce
Clyde Hall who is the founder of
hallmark cards now when hall was getting
started with hallmark the greeting card
in if she was really just getting
started it wasn't something that people
gave to each other you didn't have
birthday cards and Christmas cards and
Valentine's Day cards and what helped
really make his company take off and
launch this entire industry was
collaborations with celebrities of the
day so he partnered up with artists and
musicians and writers and people who
were well-known known quantities and
he'd leveraged their name to make his
company grow so he parted up with Norman
Rockwell and Winston Churchill and
Jackie Kennedy and they all created
their own cards and he leveraged their
brand to create his own and pretty soon
homework became known as a source of
excellence as the standard company to go
to and so you want to do the same thing
with your business if you're just
getting started and you don't know you
know how to launch it you don't know how
to get any exposure you are trying to
build a brand leverage the names of
other people have their credibility help
you grow here's how I did it when I was
first launched in my business I
high-diving Carmical com it was a
website and I shared my own thoughts and
opinions and other people started
contributing their thoughts and their
stories and their wisdom but nobody
really knew who some of these people
were you know business coaches marketing
consultants but no big names and I
thought you know what I need to get some
big names attached to this so that if
people see their names on it so I got to
join that I got to be a part of it
because this person is a part of it and
so I've started by reaching out to God
Kawasaki and Seth Godin who are both
well-known bloggers at the time and they
agreed and then I used their names to
leverage to get other people involved
and we got Michael Gerber and Zig Ziglar
and jack canfield and tons of other
people who are well known in the
entrepreneur circle and I made my way up
to getting Donald Trump involved as well
and when we
the pitch to him he saw all these other
people who are involved and he said yes
you want to share his content and once I
got him and all these other people I
stopped having to promote it because the
author's look at it and say hey all
these people are involved in it I want
to jump on board that train as well and
that's kind of where we hit a tipping
point so that's how to practically apply
it to your business you may not be able
to start right now I'd base and go after
somebody like Donald Trump hey you may
be able to go for it if you think you
can you know go take that shot but if
it's too big a shot then start smaller
and work your way up you know get get
somebody who's a little bit ahead of you
and use their name to get something a
little bit ahead of them and continue to
build up and by the time you get to that
Donald Trump or whoever it is that
you're trying to reach you can show them
all the people that are involved in this
project and make it a lot more appealing
to them so to build your brand a fast
way to do it instead of just trying to
do it all yourself is leverage other
people's name recognition get them
involved through collaborations with you
to help your company grow believe for
those you watch this video you'll like
it you can support me by subscribing
below click on the link in the
description to support me and I'll leave
a comment let me know what you think
your comments mean a lot to me and I
appreciate them thank you so much belief